all right are
you I don't want to give it to
youv
I have to go I have to
go I have to
please need to grab the bags take the
bags yeah you need to wait outside okay
my husband's almost 80 years old he
can't yeah I can please can I no you
can't Jo there oh don't do this please
please oh got to help him get home this
is
terrible hold on to that for
is that okay with
you
please you have anything in your
pocket
no no do you have anything value in you
no unless you have a necklace
on yeah take it off
and the Rings take everything um you
give it your husband because once you
arrive at County they're going to make
you remove all
that can I call my
attorney where am I
going open your finger where am I you're
going to the day County
County
[Music]
right no
problem no problem I'm sorry your
[Music]
hearings
minut thank you here
take go
back you're making a mistake
Mist get this
off can you take it off please
I just a minute it's getting there hone
listen to me yeah I'll call get in Uber
go home I will take I will all right yes
Nails in her person she wants oh it's
coming sweetheart I got it's coming just
do you have her dri I'm sorry her driver
it's in my it's in my it's in my purse
yeah
get you need or can I give it to
it's in the it's in the it's in the blue
and white
I'm license the address on your license
is correct
yes she she needs all her she needs all
when she go when she goes to
thepit they're all in here though yes
they work if I take them here what will
happen is when you go there they Poss to
toss them out so when you go to the
there you'll meet the nurse and the
doctor and then they'll work in
conjunction with the hospital to get you
whatever you need yeah but I don't have
a list with me I
know I have a
um is it is it multiple or is just one
or two it's no there's a bag of
medication in here is that what you're
asking me she take no I know I know I
was just trying to find out like one or
two it was one or two then she maybe
could take the name down do you need
anything wel come home can I
ask can someone just get my husband
outside and I'll be I'll get i'll get
gentleman here will assist him in
any
r okay all right so now so I don't have
the meds hone they all
here give me one moment please body me
one
moment
[Music]
Airport
[Applause]
all
[Music]
there
ch
[Music]
you have your case
number okay all
[Music]
right
I'm going 06 from now from here and then
I get the case number for the
[Music]
video
up
[Music]
you want to use the out here
yeah I'll hold
you all
right
[Music]
just be careful
down
huh running
yeah I got
it okay we want to thank Morgan and
Morgan for sponsoring this body cam
video I mean I think it's pretty clear
from the body cams that we covered that
it's not always safe out there when
you're hurt it can be confusing it can
be scary you don't really know where to
turn well Morgan and Morgan is actually
the largest injury law firm in America
and in a time when you already have so
much to think about they're going to
make it super easy for you they have
completely modernized the process
because you submit your claim you sign
contracts you upload documents you talk
to your whole legal Team all on your
phone that's it an attorney is going to
review your case in just eight clicks
also they have 4,000 support staff that
can help you too which is just amazing
to think about and in terms of price
well you only pay them if you win
there's no upfront fee so if you're
injured and you want to join the over 3
million people that call them every year
you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com
LC bodycam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone s please
just be careful your head I was it
first for your fit in perfect thank
you
oh you're
welcome you want to take
my okay okay I'll
[Applause]
do huh
no that's okay I'm going to leave you
like
[Applause]
that that
mean let me leave
the the address on the LIC huh the
address
on that's a okay you
[Applause]
ahead
[Music]
because thanks again appreciate you
guys
what
okay I'm going to check you first okay
stay
still can I
76 anything you have that may change me
I have nothing on I
still7 you want to do the same for the
FR
okay 14 kilo second floor Door 17 at
United it's 1928 at 109
right
okay and then I took a 15 with
3105 and I was rival at uh
208 thank
air condition doesn't go to the back
because of the V because of the plastic
we open this a little
bit it'll be
free you'll be glad you have
it
take
wait war what I'm in to work
War
thank
you do you know do you know how how long
we're going to sit oh how long we're
going to sit here um as soon as he comes
back he's going to take you from here to
the warrant and to theity
waiting for the other officer to come
back okay yeah whatever information he
took from you I guess that's what he was
missing so he's going to H
okay so the the next place is what the
warrant what did you say h what did you
say the next place was well you see what
happened is the the warrant that they
have from you is from out of Leon
County when did they issue a warrant so
what happened is we have to we have to
take you to our warrant you for that
information to get entered and then
after that gets entered before we can
take you to to the jail to the local
jail okay because I didn't know there
was a warrant how would I know that well
we wouldn't have been able to take you
if there wasn't something in so aren't
they supposed to inform aren't they
supposed to inform me if there was a
warrant for me well I don't know the
details they had a
warrant the gentleman that you met
earlier in in the flame throws yes right
they were they were supposed to inform
you of whatever and then because it's a
because it's a counting warrant that's
how we became
involved okay all right
yeah
okay we to go now can I have can I have
can I have the one second r
yeah you're going to have have to R up
the window because it's
raining raining a lot yeah yeah been
raining okay
brother thank you man all right I'll see
you
change my qth to WM transporting a white
female ready for a
starting 6 0
03 going to roll out the windows it's
raining once we exit okay
[Music]
this say 40y
old
anding is
601 let me lock the
door
just push my glasses up a little on my
nose abolutely like that that okay thank
you no you're welcome going to go to
that office right there on the
corner let me get the door for
you
thank you how you doing this how a
SE turn this
way so it's protocol that we need to
follow you
know rules and
regulations ready we
take your time the rush go for your
head we're going to go through that door
the
corner
43 show
MEK 6
14 let how see oh you know why
yeah
let's turn on just in case start
raining how
doing